هذا الكلام حقيقه غير مبالغه الناس ممكن
يشوفوا هذا مبالغ او حاله وعاطفه لا
الحقيقه هذا الكلام غير الانجازات
السياسيه
انا اتحدث لك عن شخصيه معاي بن سفيان ماذا
يعني فعلا هذا الرجل هذا الرجل معاويه بن
ابي سفيان هذا الشاب اليافع اللامع الذي
نشا بين بطحاء مكه وجبالها ابن سيد سادات
قريش هذا الرجل الذي خرج الى الشام في ظل
احداث مضطربه و ملتهبه كانت في العالم
الاسلامي بعد احداث الفتنه قام معاويه بن
ابي سفيان في ذلك الوقت بحمايه وحفظ
المنجزات الحضاريه التاريخيه التي تحققت
في عهد الخلافه الراشده فاسس معاويه بن
ابي سفيان واحده من اكبر واعظم
الامبراطوريات التي عرفها البشر في زمانهم
في ذلك الوقت التي هي الدوله الامويه
الامبراطوريه هذه الدوله الامويه كانت
اكبر بثلاثه اضعاف يعني حجمها اكبر بثلاثه
اضعاف من الامبراطوريه الرومانيه هذه
الدوله الدوله الامويه بلغ نفوذها وامتد
نفوذها الى جميع قارات الارض المعروفه
بذلك الوقت اسيا واوروبا وافريقيا هذه
الدوله حكمت الثلث العالم نحن نتحدث عن
ثلث العالم حكمت هذه الدوله وتحت يعني
سكانها بلغوا 60 مليون نسمه وهذا عدد ضخم
بمعايير ذلك الزمن اذا نحن نتكلم عن رجل
اسس هذه الامبراطوريه التي غيرت من شكل
العالم حكمت قرابه ثلث العالم اذا هذه
الخريطه الكبرى التي غيرت هذا الشكل وهذا
العالم
والى اليوم امتداداتها قائمه بمعنى صوره
العالم الاسلامي وشكل خريطه العالم
الاسلامي تقريبا هو تعود بشكل كبير الى
تلك انت ذكرت انه دور في حفظ الطوائف
المسيحيه العربيه كيف
له اثر كبير جدا في هذا في هذا الجانب
وحتى نفهم هذا الامر اولا ما نتكلم عن
معاويه كخليفه للمسلمين معاويه بصفته
اميرا للشام ثم خليفه المسلمين حينما
اصبحت دمشق عاصمه الخلافه الامويه ولم يكن
فقط قائدا وزعيما للمسلمين فحسب هو كان
ايضا مرجعا ومسؤولا وحاميا للطوائف من غير
المسلمين الموجوده في في العالم الاسلامي
كما ذكرت لك قبل قليل انه العالم الاسلامي
المدن في العالم الاسلامي كان فيها نسبه
كبيره بل ربما في حاله في حاله هم
الاكثريه من غير المسلمين فلذلك اذا نسبه
كبيره من سكان البلاد من غير المسلمين كان
معاويه هو بمثابه المرجع الذي تعود اليه
هذه الطوائف المسيحيه بل انه في المصادر
المسيحيه تطلق على معاويه بن او سفيان لقب
الزعيم المستنير السمح وكانت هذه الطوائف
المسيحيه حينما تختلف فيما بينها اختلفت
مثلا طائفه العاقبه والمارونيه وغيرهم حول
مساله طبيعه المسيح يرجعون الى معاويه بن
ابي سفيان هو الذي يفصل بينهم في هذه
المسائل
ويفض هذا النزاع وهذا فض النزاع هو حمايه
لهذه الطوائف من ان تتقاتل فيما بينها
ابن سفيان كان وزير ماليته مسيحي كان
طبيبه الخاص مسيحي كان شاعره في البلاط
مسيحي وعين واليا على حمص مسيحي اسمه ابن
اثال وهذا مشهد حضاري غيبته عنا هذه
الخطابات